welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel studios shongxi in the
legend of the tin rings just
dropped a new trailer for this movie
coming in september
i am back from my exile ready to talk
about more marvel stuff with you guys
yes my breakdown of loki episode 3 is
coming trust me it's gonna be a good one
for now i gotta react to this trailer
i'm so excited for this movie so i'm
gonna react to it break down the big
highlights and then do a frame by frame
analysis i think we'll be able to get
that on the channel on saturdays take a
look
[Music]
throughout my life the ten rings
gave our family power whoa
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
loving how these rings are looking these
are vicious you are a product of all who
came before you
okay michelle you're confirmed
you are your mother whether you like it
or not
you are also your father
oh damn i told my man
what is going on
i'm loving the cinematography of this
you're
[Music]
this looks amazing
[Music]
i thought i could change my name start a
new life
[Music]
but i could never escape his shadow
[Music]
whoa
my son you can't run from your past
what
now that's not but that is that's is
that what you wanted
that's what i wanted
what what thank you
abomination versus wong holy
[ __ ] well we know abomination was coming
back but i thought he was coming in
she-hulk
what's he doing in this movie he's
looking
nasty he's got a big back fin why is
wong having to fight him right now is
that wong
it's a sorcerer he's using that's that's
a sling ring on the hand that's a spell
how are the bartenders down below not
just like watching
up in awe at this madness so abomination
one of these characters uh emil blonsky
from the first hulk movie you know that
movie that marvel studios pretends uh
didn't happen most of the time kevin
feige revealed last december that he was
going to return in she-hulk on disney
plus next year blonsky was implied to be
locked up somewhere in some prison
facility
the fact that he's now fighting in this
tournament is interesting along with the
fact that wang
is fighting this tournament it sounds
like the stakes of win woo's fighting
tournament are so high
that every power player on earth needs a
champion who's gonna enter that bracket
so by wong
entering it means that the sorcerers
need some kind of warrior to compete for
it
because kind of like how they were
protecting the time stone these 10 rings
falling in the wrong hands could really
upset the balance of power between the
different dimensions even but by putting
freaking abomination in this
maybe this is a way he could fight for
his freedom thunderbolt ross decided hey
if you want to come back to serving your
country again
go on and fight for us in this fighting
tournament but before i continue thanks
to 1440 for sponsoring this video
so how do you stay up to date with the
latest news like if you're turning to
social media or random web pages to get
your news it can be hard to know what to
trust or what's really just opinion
pretending to be news well 1440 is your
all-in-one source of impartiable
digestible news
with limited time each morning to catch
up on what's going on in the world the
creators of 1440 andrew and tim
set out to provide the latest news
without the click bait and spin so that
you can come to your own conclusions all
you have to do is go to join1440.com
new rockstars and enter your email
address to get started for three so
let's see what the news is today
i like to scroll through the big
headlines of the day to take in the
first couple sentences and then go back
to dive deep on anything i'm interested
in ooh el salvador making bitcoin
official currency
yeah i'm gonna need to know more there
1440 is both the year that the first
printing press was invented
and is the number of minutes in a day
precious minutes that you don't want to
waste on some junky bias news reporting
so get informed without the bs today
click the link in this video's
description and subscribe to 14 40 for
free
this could be how shang chi is dragged
back into this after being raised under
an abusive upbringing from his father
when woo aka
the mandarin he escaped for 10 years
living a life as a valet in san
francisco but now that this tournament
is happening
his father needs him to fight as his
champion to keep the rings in this
family but that also looks like it's
going to bring up a rivalry between his
sister xiling
and a bunch of other fighters you got
florian montiano uh playing
razor fist you got the mandarin's
right-hand man death dealer
i'm wondering what other great warriors
from the marvel cinematic universe we're
gonna see show up in this bracket like
are we gonna see mutants or we can see
omega red now one of the other crazier
shots that i'm surprised they show in
the trailer this uh
dragon in the water right now just to be
clear here uh simulu said that thin fan
film is not going to be
in chiang chi but clearly some dragon is
and we know from some funko pop releases
that there was a
great protector dragon that's going to
factor in the plot somehow
we know from that jackson wang song that
played in the first trailer there was
that lyric you woke up the dragon
so while that specific giant dragon in
the comics may not be the version of the
dragon that's in this movie
clearly it is inspiring they're
obviously doing a lot of stuff to change
some of the you know
problematic nature of the early shanghai
comics like obviously with his father
being merged with the character of the
mandarin and
and again this is the real mandarin not
the fake mandarin from iron man 3. this
is the real guy the real head of the 10
rings this crime organization that's
been the institute since the beginning
look i'm just blown away by this trailer
i have a much clearer picture of what
this movie is in scope compared to the
first trailer we're getting a peek into
the whole corner of the world here and
the way this is going to expand the
marvel cinematic universe as we knew it
i mean i just can't wait to go through
this trailer frame by frame uh even the
shot of win woo
and chung chi doing this kind of laser
tug of war with the
with the ten rings like where is this
exactly what is that weird red
scaly texture behind chung chi is some
of this conflict gonna be jumping around
through different periods in history
like you see shang chi
in what i thought was kind of an ancient
mythological setting where we saw the fu
dogs now he's there
saying is this what you wanted this film
looks colorful it looks
exciting it looks like we're going to
see some actually good stunt fighting
which you don't
see in every marvel title to be honest
and now i get to make theory videos of
how
shanghi is going gonna set up she-hulk i
i didn't think i'd be able to do that
look i got
a lot i gotta break down but first my
loki episode three breakdown is on the
way
please please support us by checking out
our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com we got a loki at a
time
shirt that is awesome we got a new
augmented reality shirt some
miss minutes crap you can get all of
which goes directly to support us and
what we're doing here at new rockstars
my breakdown of this trailer is going to
come out saturday i think it's the
fastest i can get it out thanks for
bearing with me follow me at ea voss
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you